okay so last week things got a little
weird can you blame me I've covered 67
episodes of this show and I'm only
barely over halfway yeah you heard me
right
I'm only halfway but how could that be I
hear you ask him aren't I on the last
arc of the series well yeah I am and
it's over 60 episodes long so yeah this
episodes it's a girthy one to girthy for
me to cover in a single video so in
order for me to have this video out in
time and to avoid having my editors
computer explode I'm decided to split
this final arc into two separate videos
but trust me there's more than enough
material to facilitate two separate
videos in this instance and the material
I'll be covering in today's video has
some honestly incredibly touching and
beautiful throwbacks - classic Dragon
Ball moments in the series oh and also
despite me splitting this arkin - I
still need to cover more episodes in
this video than practically any other
review I've done in the past and that
includes the first part of this which
covered two arcs in one video why do I
feel a headache already anyway in this
video I'll be covering the recruitment
phase of the universe survival arc as
well as all the mayhem that came
packaged with this large section of the
story like all of my other reviews I'm
writing this introduction before I've
actually started rewatching the series
so sit back relax and smash those like
and subscribe buttons because today we
are diving headfirst into my review for
Dragon Ball super z' universe survival
arc
/ the recruitment are the recruitment
art part but also the filler stuff
beforehand
all right so this is pretty much the
same situation of the last episode
Dragon Ball super likes to shove a bunch
of random disconnected mini arcs and
standalone episodes sandwiched in
between its main story points so I'm
gonna quickly go over these to get to
the main entree but hey on the bright
side I actually really liked some of
these sort of kinda episode 68 this
episode isn't one of those episodes that
I actually kind of liked in fact I
really didn't like it it centers around
making a wish in the Dragon Balls or
something Goku wants to wish King Kai
back and Bulma wants to wait for
something else it's honestly one of the
weaker episodes for me in our of the
series episode 69 this episode is one
that I think is disliked more than liked
by the vast majority of the fandom but I
actually kind of liked it because it's
just so weird it's like this strange
self-aware but not really fever dream
but also a crossover with Akira
Toriyama's two most successful manga
properties also
Bokke gets a slick new hairstyle for
like three seconds but yeah episode 70
this episode has the spirit of one of
the most enjoyable filler episodes in
the original run of Dragonball for those
of you out there that do not know what
I'm talking about in Dragon Ball Z there
was an episode most fans affectionately
labeled as the driving episode why you
ask because it was an episode about drag
driving what can I say the Dragon Ball
community were as simple people point is
the episode despite not having anything
to do with the main story it didn't
contradict pre-established mechanics or
attempt to reintroduce anything
meaningful it was just a great slice of
life opportunity for real fun character
interactions and comedy this episode and
Dragon Ball super
now affectionately labeled the baseball
episode because they play baseball
nailed it is just like its companion in
the original anime it's just a whole
mess of fun with loads of wonderful
interactions and a surprisingly touching
ending for Yamcha if you haven't seen it
I highly recommend it it's one of my
favorites episode 71 and 72 okay so
these two episodes are the first of
three kalam three entirely unrelated
separate mini arcs as is the nature of
these pre arc filler episodes anyways
these first two episodes and their story
are serviceable my interest was held
fairly well throughout and unlike the
Goku black arc it had an ending that
while not special doesn't make me want
to claw
is out with the rusty fork hashtag
progress essentially the first episode
follows a Goku that is consistently
looking behind his back paranoid that
he's being followed leading to all sorts
of hijinks but the climax of the first
episode is a shocker
it turns out hid has been given his name
to assassinate and does just that
sending a blow to Goku's chest stopping
his heart thankfully though Goku has a
contingency plan to bring him back to
life which actually works shockingly in
the second episode leading to their
fight to continue with the final
episodes conclusion revealing that Goku
put the hit out on himself
I actually undisciplined 73 and 74 a
modern-day masterpiece of Dragonball
storytelling petting as the debut for
Dragon Balls new leading man berry Khan
the victim of success he falls into a
chasm of his own creation in the wake of
a parasitic outbreak again this is Barry
demonstrating his range as a performer
and a character he becomes the tragic
hero as the story comes to a close and
the antagonist Gohan wins the day this
two-part Shakespearean tragedy tells the
incredibly yet devastating tale of
hubris betrayal and deceit center around
Dragon Balls newest and most physically
attractive new leading man Barry Khan 2
out of 10 bad episode episode 75 and 76
off the back of an incredibly boring
collection of episodes covering a weird
parasitic relationship and no I'm not
over the loss of Barry as the focus
character he did nothing wrong except
lightsheet steel and possibly Splott
something sinister but who among us is
perfect this third and final mini Ark is
the best of the three and is honestly
one I've returned to on a number of
occasions before this rewatch and it
very well might contain some of my
favorite character scenes to come out of
Dragon Ball super and to think it all
centers around Crillon it starts off as
Goku instigates a reunion between
Crillon himself and Master Roshi as they
attempt to learn more from the Hermit
however brewing beneath the surface of
Crillon is a palpable insecurity that if
you know the character and are familiar
with them has always been there really
complimented by some understated music
and gorgeous storyboarding it really
drives home how isolated and small
Crillon feels no pun intended
especially when next to goku coming to a
head during a trip planned by Master
Roshi billed to expose them to their
greatest enemies of their past
Krillin freezes and Goku takes action
noticing this Goku tries to reassure him
leading to Crillon exclaiming I'm not
like you Goku I'm scared that was a
genuinely great line as I got the
feeling that while he said this he
wishes he was more like Goku but this
isn't the first time that he's thought
of this that it's something he
recognized about himself and he knew
that no matter what he's never going to
be Goku if you haven't seen it I highly
recommend it it's more uplifting toward
the end which is nice but those dramatic
scenes towards the beginning are my
favorite by far great mini art and that
concludes the pre universe survival arc
filler material and all bad in fact some
of them were great so without further
ado let's dive into the main stuff
episode 77 finally we are starting the
arc and what I'll be discussing today
can be divided up into three sections
number one the setup number two the
preliminary tournament end matches that
come with that nonsense and number three
the recruitment arc itself the episode
comes with some new visual updates and a
brand new Opie that is hoppin I'm sorry
I'm a big fan of the Opie the entire
visual in art style is practically the
exact same with some minor changes that
make a significant difference I think
all done in post to desaturate the
colors and to thicken up the lines
overall a decent improvement I think in
addition to these new visuals in the
episode we get a ton of setup in short
some time has passed since the last arc
that maybe wants to do bad things to me
Aizen did goku is going about his
farming stopping bandits and goes to
meet recent bearers for training yet
again all before remembering zetas
wanted to hold a tournament Goku then
takes upon himself to remind the little
ticking time bombs yes no there's two
one from the e2 to Future Trunks
universe that makes me sad to think
about yeah well that universes Zeno now
bumps with this universe Zeno and Goku's
meeting with them leaves these little
sociopaths to announce the torment of
power requiring 10 representatives from
each universe to participate episode 78
in the space of one episode Goku has put
the entire multiverse at risk to
effectively scratch an itch no I won't
go as far as to suggest that Goku knew
that this massive threat would happen in
fact I'm certain he believes Zeno was
nothing to be afraid of as every
encounter he's had with the little guy
up until now was pleasant sort of but
even in that case I'm sure he didn't
directly blame Zeno as he was reacting
that could only be addressed that way or
whatever point being I don't think it's
as simple as saying Goku put the
universe in danger now I can easily see
the argument for it and in some ways I
agree with it just not very strongly but
anyway that's essentially the gist of
this episode the grand priest a
character that looks feels and is
sometimes shot in is super evil but
totally isn't evil sort of way comes and
reveals the stakes of the term into
power down into the universes with the
worst levels would participate in an
elimination battle royal style match
with the last universe left standing
earning a wish on the super Dragon Balls
oh and babe won't die that last part is
important I actually really liked this
episode as it does two things really
well it gives us a long-term goal being
the tournament of power and it's ending
as well as a short-term goal to look
forward to right away
this is tremendous for story pacing and
takes the form of a preliminary contest
between universe 7 which happens to be
the second worst round universe by some
metric against the single worst ranked
universe the ninth when we haven't seen
yet Goku is instructed by bears to take
responsibility for finding two other
fighters who make up the numbers for the
preliminaries n o Expo which he does in
Gohan and majin buu who really hasn't
done anything in super yet except eat
pudding not share lose to beerus and
sleep at really inopportune times also I
love how Golan reacts to Goku's news
like any sane person would stressing and
looking at Goku to take accountability
it's at this point that they decide
keeping the consequences of the
tournament is best kept to themselves
for some reason I don't know it's not
like the gang has a history of causing
mass hysteria they arrive at the grounds
for the mini face off against the
representatives from universe 9 3
wolf-like warriors known as the trio
tada jer take the stage episode 79 first
up is majin buu vs. basil from the 9th
universe and if I'm being honest
this fight is fun as all hell it's by no
means super dramatic or a spectacle but
it's certainly not boring either there's
some great character moments with majin
buu and the action is complemented
terrifically by the stretching and fluid
animation style it's a refreshing
episode center around majin buu it took
79 episodes to get here but they finally
did something with them episode 80
next up Gohan vs. lavender go on in this
episode I was curious to see what they
would actually do
with the p-ting him up against the
crafty underhanded lavender seemed to me
like the perfect complement to Gohan's
good boy demeanor and it was in a lot of
ways both from an aesthetic and story
perspective right from the get-go
lavender removes the use of Gohan's
vision using his unique abilities
there's honestly some great action here
and it's benefited immensely by how
simple the story of the battle was go on
effectively has to use his intelligence
and composure to find lavender he has to
feel his presence and has to wait for
the sounds he makes it's a very
enjoyable and easy watch that ultimately
ends in a draw episode 81 Goku vs
Bergamo because of the way the last two
matches have ended there isn't really
any pressure on Goku as they can't
really lose the match at this point
majin buu born and gohan drew so
thinking of it like that universe 7 is
very much in the driver's seat here and
that's not to say it's a bad thing or
that Goku should always be on the back
foot and he shouldn't but there's no
tension in this fight as Goku proceeds
to dominate the intrigue in the prior
matchups came from us not knowing how
majin buu would battle against as we
haven't really seen much from him and in
the case of going on it was the
interesting story he told in there with
lavender but also again us not knowing
how capable he would be against the
universe 9 fighter but in the case of
Goku we know he should be totally fine
and he totally is so we are effectively
just waiting for him to win it's not
even played out in a way that lets us
sit back and watch as Bergamo
understands what he's gotten himself
into either with Goku so I'm not really
sure where the interest and entry before
this fight was supposed to come from and
part of me feels like Toei animation
knew this because topo has a match with
Goku setup right afterwards however all
in all Goku spinal matchup against the
final member of the 9th Universe was the
weakest of the three I think quite
obviously episode 82 while all the
prelim matches have been happening the
Supreme Kai of the 11th universe who is
coincidentally or perhaps appropriately
called Kai convinces the xenos to allow
his bodyguard to fight Goku this is
revealed to be a doctor robotnik looking
sort of character taking the stage to
face off against Goku somewhat
interesting Lee this guy has a unique
moveset implementing a lot of techniques
in the forms of various locks that
dislocate goku shoulder but naturally
goku ignore the fact that this would
render anyone's arm completely useless
while dislocated and yeats his way out
of there before showing Tavo some of his
girthy power Super Saiyan blue Kaioken
times whatever I don't know but we can't
see any more of that fight because we
got a statement for the tournament of
power next episode episode 83 so this is
the beginning of the recruitment mini
arc within which is the greater universe
survival arc yeah I know
Gaea thick one Goku and code traveled
back to capsule Corp to outline a plan
for gathering the necessary fighters
Monaka is of course naturally at the top
of Goku's list but is quickly shot down
by beerus leading to Goku and Gohan
agreeing that themselves Vegeta piccolo
majin buu Crillon Android 18 and her
brother and Master Roshi for some
inexplicable reason are the individuals
that should make up the first 9 leaving
one space free so first things first
gotta go ask for Gina who is having
something of a nervous breakdown with
Bulma just being super pregnant get it
well Vegeta can't focus on anything
while his daughter is about to be born
so we smacks the baby out of bulla and
they end up calling the kid bulla it's a
cute episode and now Vegeta is on board
episode 84 already so right off the bat
I really enjoy the idea of revisiting
old relationships for the sake of
recruitment in this story in this act
specifically - as we are journeying to a
tournament of power and we need to feel
the best team we can whether or not they
have been an active part of the story
doesn't really much matter at this point
in a convenient albeit unintentional way
the nature of the recruitment feels
appropriately desperate and slapdash
which honestly works in a lot of ways
for me and was the toner I assume
they're going for additionally this
episode is one of my favorites from a
visual and choreographic perspective go
on and Goku venture to recruit Crillon
an 18 for the tournament leading to go
on challenge and krillen to aspire just
testing his power which I adore because
Crillon wins with tactics rather than
raw power I'm all about that nonsense in
this match Crillon demonstrates a new
technique he's developed it's like a
super solar flare or Te'o can or
whatever your persuasion is Goku sing
this gets excited and so a contest
between Goku and the chrome dog himself
is set up atop of roof the setting and
choreography for both of these fights I
enjoyed but more so that Goku fight
patoshik ashita an incredible action
animator demonstrates some of his
fantastically imaginative battle
choreography that you really just gotta
check out to fully appreciate for
yourself but then this happens
Goku Super Saiyan blue kamehameha first
curling this is sort of
silly sure I mean it does have the
built-in excuse that Goku is holding
back but I mean how much is he holding
back like all of this it's that what's
the point that him being blue than just
testing his resolve yeah 18 gets
involved leading to herself and krillen
joining and reminding Goku that this is
a free-for-all not a one-on-one contest
episode 85 this is the episode where we
finally get more than one story running
in tandem with the main plot go on and
Goku decide to go their separate ways go
on to train with and recruit pickles and
Goku to head over to den days so that he
can find Android 17s location on his
weights ten days Goku discovers majin
buu or what's left of him after his
sudden and dramatic weight loss
transformation apparently he got all
sight after the expo and decided to get
into the best shape he could thankfully
he's a magical creature that has the
excuse of using magic to lose weight
otherwise I'd be wincing again but yeah
looking good and the little tussle
wasn't bad either
Goku then finds his way up to ten days
also in this episode is some
interactions between go on and piccolo
which I will have more to talk about on
at a later point in this video we got
some glimpses into the other Kai's and
destroyer gods of their universe is
discussing strats but it all boils down
to nothing Champa however does tell kama
to recruit more Saiyans so that's neat
this is also the first time we get to
see Jared the strongest fighter from
universe 11 cool episode 86 this is one
of the prettiest episodes in all of
Dragon Balls suit the use of color
outstanding storyboarding terrific
background art which doesn't get enough
praise and some brilliant animation by
now quítate to put the cherry on the top
it's a gorgeous episode and it all
centers around go who's recruiting of
android 17 who has started a family
after the sell games and settled down as
a park ranger of sorts protecting
endangered animals on this island we get
a nice fight between the two albeit an
unrealistic one I think and we also get
a small mention of lube - I'm glad they
did this great episode episode 87 this
is part 2 to the last episode and it's
really really weird and not really weird
ain't a good way either let me explain
while the last episode felt like Dragon
Ball this will sort of felt more like an
episode of Captain Planet I didn't even
see that show way before my time
so these space posters show up because
something has to convince seventeen to
fight in the tournament of power so why
not space poachers anyway
they steal this rare cow or something
forcing Goku and 17 to pursue the
baddies
they for all their evil plans and save
the super rare cow all as well 17 agrees
to fight the torment of power on the
condition someone will protect his
Island while he's away and so Goku puts
Goten and Trunks to protect the cow and
stuff episode 88 and now we come to the
Gohan episode well technically it's the
Gohan and piccolo episode but let's be
real here toy doesn't give a rat's
behind about piccolo now so I digress
this is the Goldman episode and a lot of
people will point to this as an
important moment when it comes to the
revival or resurgence of Gohan's
character and it is but not really
let me explain my point of view here
when go one is chosen by Goku to be a
participant in his little skirmish with
the ninth Universe he was very much in
civilian mode we've seen him start
reading again thanks to episode 30 which
at the very least showed a marked
improvement to the state he was in in
the resurrection effort but let's not
speak of that at this point point is go
on and sort of being training semi
consistently but when this episode
begins piccolo remarks and I quote so
this is your current level implying
either going hasn't been consistently
training with piccolo if at all and that
this was piccolo confirming to himself
what Gohan's current output was capable
of and he wasn't impressed then we get
this interaction between piccolo and
Goku about Gohan Goku says that Gohan is
out of practice further reinforcing the
notion that Gohan hasn't been training
much if at all since that one time we
saw him train earlier in the series
piccolo agrees to join the tournament of
power and also agrees to bring Gohan
back up to speed but let's not let the
large number of episodes that have
elapsed since the terminal was announced
distract us from the reality of the
situation from the moment the grand
priests announces the tournament of
power they have a little over 40 hours
to feel the team and ready themselves
and by the time go on and piccolo have
this interaction in episode 88 half of
that time has already passed which
brings me to my central argument as to
why I don't like this for Gohan while
him being involved in this is nice the
cleanup for his character in this arc is
the literary equivalent of sweeping dust
under the rug and they even try to hack
him back to his time as a kid training
under piccolo with plenty of visual
callbacks look if the dinosaur and
they're a bit like steak but the
difference is that the young go on had a
year to prepare himself for the same
invasion even then it wasn't enough but
that was what it looked like to treat an
important character with care and
respect and let me tell you even if it's
trying to tell
that this is all it takes to reawaken
Gohan's power and super it's not in the
slightest bit earned to me and doesn't
do anything except devalue the power he
once had what episode might be what
Dragon Ball super is saying it takes to
get back to this point but in reality it
doesn't begin to scratch the surface if
they were really concerned about
bringing Gohan back into the fold and
they'd have given him a build up
gradually but they didn't because to
them Gohan isn't worth that right now
again I'm not saying you can't like this
episode he'll if you're a fan of the
character I get it you can like it it's
great but wouldn't you want something
more substantial over something rushed
and slapdash for the sake of plot
something that's for the character
enough for the character to serve an
endpoint personally I would anyway
that's my main takeaway from this
episode along with our first glimpse of
universe 6 as additional Saiyans episode
89 in this episode we get a whole bunch
of stuff
it's got Goku Roshi and even tension and
purely by coincidence the episode kicks
off with tension Han in his dojo which
is cool for his character to have done
for himself it suits him too considering
his background but the episode primarily
acts as a mini episode centered around
this girl with the unfortunate reality
of being named yeren ro she acts like a
weirdo and then Goku arrives okay look
essentially this episode acts as a way
for Goku to recruit Master Roshi and and
even though this is considered the
tension on episode he barely plays a
role in it though he does get recruited
by Goku so that's something in essence
urine is an underhanded person who winds
up causing mischief that gets rectified
by the end the important takeaway here
is that Master Roshi and tension hun are
in the tournament now episode 90 this
episode is one of those really well
boarded episodes we get very interesting
choreography backgrounds color and
artwork it's a very pretty episode but I
wish the story got more care than it
actually did in the end the episode
itself hinges on this confrontation
between Goku and his son gohan who has
been training SuperDuper hard for a
super long time like at least a day and
essentially he wants to prove to himself
that he is enough to stand and fight
with his father in the tournament he
wants to test his abilities which
honestly is cool but again he's been
taking fighting seriously for like a
little over a day now when you think
about it like that
it's hard to take this scene as
seriously as super wants us to take it
right now or at least that's how I felt
when I watched it regardless if I was to
assume that much much more went into
building to this
the episode works perfectly fine which
means to me there's nothing wrong with
the episode itself in isolation just
it's build up go on and piccolo mosey on
up to tension and Goku challenging them
to a 2v2 match ultimately leading to
Gohan pushing things super far demanding
that his father take it as seriously as
he can which he does well sort of I mean
he doesn't go all out like kaio-ken
times 20 or whatever that nonsense is
but he does turn on the Jets enough for
Gohan to push his limits ending in a
nice father-son moment between the two
characters it's genuinely really nice to
see that and if I haven't stressed it
enough already
this episode is stunningly beautiful
with maybe my favorite shot in the
entire series episode 91 at this point
in the show all recruitment has been
completed for universe 7
Goku is training in the gravity chamber
with we switch ITA's screaming in the
hyperbolic time chamber Roshi is even
trying to temper his desires and so on
through the view of the shadows we get
to see all the universes assembling
their fighters to universe 9 does having
a lot of trouble finding anyone to feel
the team outside of the trio universe
six sees it down and out frost feeling
the effects of his reputation being
ruined after the tournament in season 3
as he is recruited by hit for their team
the episode effectively hops from
universe to universe showing their key
players but the main takeaway from this
episode is one of the most irritating
things to come out of this arc vagine'
pooh is asleep again episode 92 I hate
and I mean this the excuse majin buu has
to be taken out of the tournament but if
it means we get someone better it's at
least gonna cushion the blow for me so
Goku goes to mr. Sainz and completely
fails are trying to wake up majin buu no
surprise there give me something good
toy once he gets back to the team
piccolo has revealed the truth about the
tournament and its consequences to
everyone causing them to feel
understandably betrayed after learning
that they were lied to
Goku apologizes despite it really being
Gohan's idea and everyone forgives him
they're all in this together to the
bitter end
more talking happens and then Goku is
inspired to seek out a replacement
someone far better than majin buu but
far far worse at the same time freezes
[Music]
this episode also covers some more
antics from universe 6 combo tries @e
Chandler sayin recruit from his home
planet her name is cauliflower and he's
trying to help her to turn Super Saiyan
in a really really really weird way like
he describes it as a tingly feeling in
the back okay dude like please just stop
making the legendary rage form of your
people so incredibly lame anyway she
learns to transform almost immediately
thrilling I know you think if it was
that easy so I'm saying out a very
entire population or even history would
have stumbled upon the form eventually I
don't know stupid episode 93
so everyone questions or straight-up
refuses to involve someone like Frieza
but Goku comes up with the great idea of
utilizing fortune teller Baba's 24-hour
return policy which would give Frieza
enough time to participate but not grant
him life again it's a good plan if you
ask me meanwhile in universe 6 the
Saiyans continue to prepare with Kali
flood getting more and more adept with
her new form another sand by the name of
Cael a meek unassuming Shahi female sand
tries to learn the form too but fails
time and again leading to a frustration
crawling beneath the surface turning her
into the green haired legendary Super
Saiyan yeah whatever I don't really know
what to do with this information I
suppose she's a wild card it's not
uninteresting I just don't really care
about the character yet we get more
glimpses of other universe preparing for
the tournament while universe fours
destroyer Katella is informed of
universe sevens plan to revive Frieza
and thus begins his plan to sabotage the
initiative but who cares about that
because right now we get my favourite
scene maybe in all of the show I adored
this interaction between Goku and Frieza
it's tense there's this feeling in the
air that something could go wrong at any
moment with these two characters vying
for the upper hand in this deal the use
of color is brilliant and the cherry
blossoms falling from the heavens
representing rebirth are appropriately
sinister and that's not even mentioning
Moscow news iowa's performance here as
Goku this is Goku at his best to me and
he's appropriately serious and himself
more importantly in this scene no stupid
super Goku here folks the deal however
is made Frieza will fight for universe 7
but only on the condition but if they
win he will get his life back
appropriately targeting Goku's a weak
point
love it episode 94 to be perfectly
honest this arc of the show has been
significantly better than a lot of what
I'd seen before the Goku black arc was
entertaining very entertaining and I did
enjoy it while it was on the air but as
a complete story it left a lot to be
desired but this arc it's so simple
that it's much easier to make sense of
and therefore even when things like
majin buu happen
stuff like Frieza can completely
reinvent the atmosphere surrounding an
upcoming event like the Tournament of
power and if that wasn't all this
episode had one of my absolute favorite
moments in all of Dragonball not just
super all of Dragonball I know I'm not
talking about freeze up punching Goku in
the gut well yes that was a great moment
it's not what I'm talking about so the
episode kicks off as Katella is starring
more due to with the ninth universe's
god of destruction Sidra basically
informing him about Frieza and inspiring
him to work together with him to assign
assassins to take Frieza out before he
can take part aside from that Goku lets
everyone back at bulma's place know that
he needs to go pick up Frieza from Baba
and after he leaves 17 and the rest of
the team start to arrive lovely great
now time for my favorite part and moment
I honestly missed the very first time I
saw it but one that really brought a
tear to my eye when I noticed it so the
scene begins as Goku is waiting
patiently outside of Baba's palace for
Frieza and it looks like he's just
entertaining himself keeping busy with
some sparring and he is but it's not
just simple sparring Goku is reliving
the specific fight he had against his
grandpa Gohan the last time he saw him
strike for strike jump for jump beat for
beat what an absurdly touching and
perfect Easter egg for those among us
that would notice beautiful once that is
over Frieza shows up finally and in a
dramatic fashion with really pretty
artwork to the to share a really fun
character moment before they are
ambushed by the assassin sent by the
other universes gods of destruction this
is such a fun situation for these two
mortal enemies to be caught in together
Goku knows that he needs to leave ASAP
for the tournament but Frieza unable to
restrain himself shoots one of them from
the sky without a care in the world
guess we're fighting our way out of here
episode 95 and finally we get the most
action-packed episode of this arc so far
and my god is it great the last three
episodes have shown us
not like resurrection F did but at his
most conniving and sinister this is top
tier Frieza without exaggeration slicing
through the assassins like butter
sometimes literally and all with a smile
on his face you can tell this is the
most fun he's had in a very long time
and I am here for it one of the minions
was assigned the duty of delivering a
specific special attack an energy blast
given to them by universe 9s god of
destruction it's literal destroyer
energy and it poses a real threat to
both Goku and Frieza Frieza things he
gets the upper hand on the blast but it
finally reaches its target and connects
with Freeza Freeza is far stronger now
than we ever gave him credit for he can
overcome it and control it returning it
to size disposing of its wielder with
ease and then using it on an unprepared
goke this all feeds into the notion that
Frieza is a complete unpredictable wild
card in this upcoming tournament that
cannot be trusted
using this moment of reprieve Frieza
makes contact with universe 9s destroyer
to negotiate Frieza it's clear is
obviously not a man of his word and at
the first chance he attempts to bargain
elsewhere for a better deal than Goku
offered however the conversation is cut
short by bears who blows the blast away
from Goku with ease much to Goku's
relief there's clearly some tension that
needs to be addressed between the two
and so they have a quick scuffle in the
moments that they have left before they
absolutely need to leave the fight isn't
fantastic or anything but it's flashy in
the artwork is spectacular supplied by
non kosher schita it's another wonderful
addition to the series the to lend
massive shots in each other before
calling it quits they make their way to
the team it's time to travel to the
world of void for the tournament of
power then that concludes the
recruitment ark so what did I think
honestly looking back over the sections
of the show not having to wait week to
week to week for another episode made it
much much more enjoyable this time
around No obviously I still have my
issues I don't really like how the new
sands achieved their powers and I am
massively unimpressed with how they just
write out majin buu like that I'm no
issue with the staff not wanting any
character to take part mind you but at
least create a decent reason to exclude
them
you know maybe they are kidnapped or
maybe they don't want to or maybe their
powers are forbidden or something my
point is anything but falling asleep is
okay especially seeing as this isn't the
first time they've
that excuse with this specific character
the one minut aspect that made this
somewhat tolerable for me was that this
substitute was a much much more
interesting character to me prior to
learning Frieza was gonna take a spot in
the universe 17 I never really carried
all that much for the tournament I mean
I was into it
sort of but when Frieza was added to the
mix it created an entirely different
vibe around the ark on top of that the
episodes Frieza had in this section are
some of my absolute favorites from the
entire series and that includes Dragon
Ball Z from a visual perspective I
thought that this arc was really strong
too long gone are the days where Goku
looked like a plastic figure melting
under a magnifying glass now we get a
consistently higher level of model
correctness in addition to some of the
best boarded episodes in this series to
date with the Crillon episode the 17
recruitment episode and the battle
between Goku and Gohan overall I thought
this arc 'td really well in establishing
the stakes setting up the tournament and
building intrigue around the event well
ok almost everything was taken care of
we see Jared in this section maybe once
or twice he never talks and this is
supposed to be the big looming threat of
the tournament but we have no idea what
he wants cares about is I mean he could
deserve to win the tournament I don't
know it could be like another Goku but
I'll cover that in the next episode when
I tackle the entire tournament from
start to finish I can feel the headaches
already if you enjoyed this video leave
a like it really helps the channel and
if you want to keep up to date with my
videos subscribe and hit the
notification bell if you want the
subscription to actually work as always
I've been totally not mark I'll see you
guys next week and thank you so much for
watching
[Music]